four young gay men drugged assaulted and
murdered by a serial killer Stephen Paul
was free to kill again and again and
again because of a calamitous Litany of
failures by the Met police who didn't
think the deaths were suspicious now a
damning new report warns it could happen
again
his Majesty's inspectorate of constabury
found a number of areas where the Met
failed eight years ago and have kept on
failing in the investigations of sudden
deaths for not enough training for the
junior officers who get called out a
lack of supervision over those officers
unacceptable record keeping and even a
Reliance on luck to identify links
between deaths at a local level if they
get the basics wrong right at the start
the chances of categorizing the death
wrongly and therefore the danger of
something like Stephen Port happened
again goes up missing another serial
killer it's entirely possible this
report is clear that three of Stephen
port's four victims didn't have to die
if officers had only done the basics of
police work from the beginning instead
he kept on killing in the same way even
leaving two of the bodies in the same
location at this graveyard here in
parking but the police didn't connect
the dots and failed for far too long to
realize they were dealing with a serial
killer Jack was very loving caring life
and so I have a family life and solve
everything and yeah everyone just misses
him dearly Jenny and Donna's brother
Jack was port's Final victim we've not
been able to go for Jack because all
we've ever done is after fire fire and
we're still fighting to this day for a
public inquiry we're still fighting for
justice we're still fighting for
somebody to stand up
and and shove accountability
the Met police say the deaths of Anthony
walgate Gabrielle cavari Daniel
Whitworth and Jack Taylor were a tragedy
and we're sincerely sorry we failed them
and their families while as the
inspection report acknowledges we have
worked hard since the murders to
understand what went wrong and improve
how we work it highlights more we need
to do
the victim's families were told in the
inquest two years ago that police
mistakes probably led to their loved
ones deaths but this latest report
brings home the agony of knowing how
little has changed in the last eight or
four years and they must be wondering
how many more murders could have been
missed in that time Rachel Venable's Sky
News